president Trump has reportedly ordered
the Pentagon to cut the number of US
troops stationed in Germany by nearly a
third
according to government sources cited by
The Wall Street Journal around 25,000
would remain American forces have been
stationed in Germany of course since the
end of World War two for more let's
speak to German lawmaker andreas Nick
he's a member of the Bundestag Committee
on Foreign Affairs it's so glad to have
you with us was the German government
informed about this move and from all I
know there was no official information
in communication to the German
government we also as we understand the
Pentagon has so far deferred press
inquiries to the White House and which
also pin points to the fact that this is
probably more a political decision than
one that was reached build-up based on
military expertise Aaron ekam I'm
curious about your take on on this what
are the implications of this move to cut
the numbers of US troops in Germany I
think first we have to consider that the
overwhelming part of the American
military presence in Germany is not
related to territorial defense for
Germany but is exercising headquarter
functions for a broader presence in
Europe and even Africa it is a major hub
in the global operations of US military
with particularly the Ramstein Air Base
in the Landstuhl medical facility so
this is potentially weakening u.s.
capabilities not only in the region but
globally
I can only say American military men and
their families are more than welcome in
Germany and we have cooperated very well
at a number of those aspects but where
we are I think at the moment it's hard
to assess the is the specific
consequences as long as we don't know
how which sites which units will be
affected by this
well I'm gonna ask you to think about
those consequences a little bit here and
look into the crystal ball I mean how do
you think this could impact German
American relations moving forward I mean
I would primarily focus on the on the
operational effect this are too early to
assess from what we know so far I think
a hard cap of 25,000 military presence
in Germany at all times would have a
serious impact I think also on the
capability to to move on troops around
in various scenarios if there is a
relocation for some of part of the troop
reductions to central Eastern Europe
that could have an impact on the
security situation on the eastern flank
of NATO there as well
but I think it is it is apparently meant
as a symbolic means that will further
deteriorate the atmosphere and
transatlantic relations and I expect
that there may be more of that to come
in the run of the US elections given the
tense situation in the United States
surely we'll all be watching andreas NIC
member of the German Parliament's
Foreign Affairs Committee appreciate
your making the time on a Saturday
morning thank you